JENNY BROWN: Are you suffering
death by a million paper cuts?
Hopefully not because
that sounds awful.
But if that's a metaphor
for your small file uploads
messing with your performance,
then you're in luck.
Today on "Cloud
Storage Bytes," we're
diving deep into the world
of optimizing your small file
uploads.
So stick around.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's say you're
a biotech company,
and your main
product is a software
that works with DNA across
multiple distributed machines.
Everything is great.
But whenever you add a
data set, your clients
are stuck waiting and
waiting to begin computation.
You've checked
your architecture,
and it's pretty straightforward.
A new data set comes
in, gets divided,
and uploaded to Cloud Storage,
triggering a Pub/Sub alert
for your clients
to start computing.
So what's the problem here?
And this is the tricky bit.
The amount of work each client
is responsible for changes
depending on the number of
clients connected to do work.
So having more clients
leads to smaller work blocks
as the clients balance
out that workload.
This means that
your software will
take ages to upload all
the files to Google Cloud
Storage in regions
with the highest
number of available cores.
So let's say you've
got a data set
with files of various sizes,
and you upload each file
to a regional bucket over
and over and over again.
If you were to take
a look under the hood
while this upload
takes place, you'd
see that as file size increases,
so does the throughput speed,
meaning smaller files are going
to bog you down like a death
by a million paper cuts, which,
once again, sounds rough.
The reason for smaller
files slowing things down
is because of the amount
of transactional overhead
for uploading those files.
The smaller each individual
file is the more times
this transactional overhead
adds up and gives you issues.
There is good news
here, and that comes
by way of parallel uploads.
As we hinted at in
an earlier episode,
you can use the dash
M option in gsutil
to perform a parallel copy
and dramatically increase
the performance of your uploads.
If you were to revisit your
example of the data set
from earlier and take another
peak right under the hood
this time using
parallel uploads,
you'd see significantly
higher throughput,
as that pesky
transactional overhead
is mitigated across the
multiple parallel threads.
Problem solved and
paper cuts avoided.
But how does this help
with large file uploads?
We have answers, but that's
a totally different episode.
If you want to know more
about parallel uploads
for small files, check out
the link in the description.
And don't forget to
subscribe, give us a like,
and tell us what more you want
to learn about Google Cloud
Storage.
Thank you for joining us
for this quick byte of cloud
storage.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]